because the platform is on the way
Gordon
fell asleep okay
come to the next level kitchen room we
are taking your skills to the next level
by teaching you the amazing basic tips
Great Tricks and skills to really
elevate your cooking that's right and
today we're doing a dish that I think
everyone is familiar with the burger uh
trust me these are three major proteins
you've got the beef the chicken the
turkey in fact that turkey burger
reminds me the last time I was in your
restaurant and it was exceptional oh I'm
glad you said that because everyone was
terrified cooking for you so first off
is the beef this is an Angus ground beef
and it's an 80 20 split what does that
mean it's 80 beef and 20 fat over to
here this is a a ground chicken fast and
it's made with the thighs the drums and
a little bit of the breast these white
bits there are the fat which is crucial
and then one of the most popular today
the turkey burger again legs thighs and
the breast and great content of fats
yeah super popular but also hard to cook
because it's so lean are you ready young
man let's go yeah you're the best all
right Burger Win oh my gosh competition
again I'm gonna do a Smash Burger okay
the essence of these burgers
is the quickness let me tell you that
why because it's relevant today and
every Top Chef in the country are making
Smash Burgers why you get these amazing
sort of thin patties and it's sort of
just above a sort of a golf ball size
and then you roll them and then from
there you smash them in the pan Richard
what are you doing oh man listen so I'm
doing a turkey burger and again turkey
the trick with turkey the trick with
turkey is that it's super lean so I'm
gonna actually season the ground meat
before I start cooking it I'm and I'm
gonna make an Asian inspired Burger so
I'm going to add some of my favorite uh
Asian ingredients a little bit of sesame
oil to the ground turkey again this is
99 lean so I want a little bit of fat
and a little bit more flavor in there
I'm gonna add a little fish sauce don't
be afraid of fish sauce people think oh
it's gonna taste fishy it just gives you
a little bit of umami Umami is the
flavor that makes your mouth water and
it's prevalent in so many different
Cuisines that we love of course I'm
going to add some salt I'm always
seasoning from up high so that my salt
gets all in whatever I'm seasoning I'm
going to add a little black pepper and
again continue along the Asian Vibe here
I'm going to add some chopped green
onions some scallions and then I'm gonna
grate in ginger and garlic so I have my
grater I'm just going to add that right
there get a little bit of garlic into my
mixture and a little bit of ginger root
ginger and garlic works so well together
a matter of fact any Asian dish usually
starts with ginger garlic and scallion I
got that in there I'm gonna mix it up
what are you doing over here Gordon okay
so these Smash Burgers as you've seen
okay these are literally cooked with
about three or four minutes but the
secret behind here is getting this beef
flat so I've got my pressed I've lightly
old it I've seasoned it I've got my
little Pate nothing smashed yet and I'll
show you why into the pan
and now we're going to smash them okay
basically we're gonna smash them and
we're going to press down so on
with the first one and just leave that
on there for about 10 seconds to go nice
and thin but Watch What Happens okay
lift that off
and look that burger is smashing the pan
and that's where the original Smash
Burger comes from again in nice and hot
and just push down
so the whole cooking sequence takes
place twice as quick but what we do get
is the most amazing flavor of these
Burgers now
thin and crispy okay so it's a quick
cook Richard how you cooking yours I
love that because you also got two
patties you're gonna get twice of What's
called the my yard reaction or the
Browning of proteins it's going to be
twice as delicious I'm not gonna smash
mine but I have to be really careful
because turkey can dry out very very
quick so what I've done is I've turned
my turkey into these patties now here's
a little weird thing for me I like to
make the Patty wider than the bun it's
going to be on because that lean meat is
going to shrink a little bit so I want
to have my burger sort of Encompass the
whole circumference of the bun so I have
my turkey patties now it's time to cook
here's a tip I like with any Burger as
well is I take a tiny little knife and I
poke holes inside of the ground meat so
that it doesn't turn into a meatball
meatball and burgers are related but
they're not the same thing that's going
to let air flow through the burger and
then I'm gonna of course I'm gonna cook
my my turkey burger over here I'm gonna
put a little bit of cooking oil in a pan
you want to make sure that your pan is
nice and hot but maybe not as hot as it
is when you're cooking red meat right
when I'm cooking poultry or seafood a
little less hot and then real simple
just like Gordon's it sounded so good
over there I'm gonna take my burger and
then just finally not talk finally not
talking just do a little Burger ASMR
so look at that that is where that
crispiness comes from and what I'm going
to do now is just literally press them
down again to get an even flatter and
what this does it pushes a little bit of
the juice out and then starts to flavor
the outside of that burger okay it's a
heavy heavy heavy fresh
and that's where that crispiness
comes from now from there I take
from there take the gas off turn it off
and just literally let them sit there
now I'm going to lay this up with a a
little bit of a Twist because
I love cheese on my burger okay and I
get my big slice of cheese I put it into
the pan okay you see that cheese melt
very very quickly and what I want to do
now is get a little bit of sort of salt
going in that cheese we're going to
caramelize that cheese and stick the
base of the bun on top of the cheese but
the sauce
this is beautiful okay I've got a
tablespoon of mayonnaise
a nice teaspoon of hot sauce and look at
that cheese melt now Richard so that's
going to caramelize get crispy I'm going
to stick my bun on top of it okay so
you're getting like triple texture going
on you get all these textures working
which is absolutely fantastic I love
that burger sauce I'm going lean and
meat I don't have all these sauces I'm
just making a slaw over here and right
now I have some cabbage shredded up
beautifully shredded cabbage I got some
green apples and I'm gonna make a quick
slaw so I'm going to start it just right
in this pan with a little bit of
sriracha I'm gonna I want some flavor in
this turkey because it's so lean so I
have Sriracha I have mayonnaise by the
way Gordon I have this recipe where I
add Sriracha to ranch dressing do you
like ranch dressing I love rice I love
ranch dressing when I add Sriracha to
Ranch I call it Sriracha I love that
love that now I've got some gherkins
going in my mayonnaise but watch this
okay I've got the hot sauce the
mayonnaise what's the sauce in there as
well just check my cheese out just for
10 seconds look at it
it sort of it's going dewy it's
caramelizing and this is where the magic
starts this is where Burgers start to go
next level take your bun very carefully
and stick that onto the cheese
and just literally mop up
that cheese and look what's happening to
that base of the burger watch Richard
please because this this is gonna go
crazy I don't mind you using this okay
I'm totally stealing this I don't mind
you used it okay
and look a beautiful melted cheese on
that base so I'm going to toast the top
because I want that texture in there I
want the egg fried beautifully before
the egg comes out of the pan you've got
to season that okay salt and I touch the
pepper and then from there put a little
bit of butter in that egg so it starts
to get it crispy a raw egg and a burger
not good a crispy egg in a burger is
where you want to go but just just just
fill my bun
look at the top
I mean beautiful come on Bingo right
there I've never seen that before that
that's impressive I know this is going
to San Diego I know I know this is one
of those moments My Next Level Chef
where you're like am I going home we
should I might be going home now we
share we share we share we share right I
beat tomato just for that sweetness I
like these big chunky beef tomatoes
because it's the actual size of my bun
again a little season from there
I never put white onion on a burger I
must prefer the Red Onion it's less
bitter and so much easier after you've
eaten it you haven't got the onion
breath okay right young man are we ready
for some Next Level plating I think well
you're ready for planning I still got to
make a slaw over here first I got my
turkey burger it's flipped over again I
want this Asian theme so I'm just gonna
smash a little bit of Ginger a little
bit of garlic I'm gonna throw that in
the pan with the turkey burger that I
just flipped and now I'm gonna throw in
some whole butter right because again
the turkey is so lean I'm not gonna eat
all of this butter I'm just gonna baste
the turkey with it uh and here we go
we're gonna baste this get this going
that's a fortune while you finish that
off yeah you can you can go go ahead
you're you're ahead you're ahead I had
the simple turkey burger Next Level
Burger watch carefully take my face the
crispy cheese base from there
a little touch of that special sauce
with those gherkins
next from there I've got my sliced
tomato a little touch of seasoning and
here's where the magic starts
first of all
my first Pate goes on I'm gonna flip my
egg
and then the egg goes on top
egg nice and crispy on top now just look
at those elements hear me out we're not
done from there
I go on with my next Burger the thin
crusty beautiful Pate onions on and just
a touch of that sauce
and
there you go
I promise you I kid you not you can go
all over the world for a beautiful
Burger but this here is a Next Level
Burger coming to a Kitchen near you soon
yours if you follow me turkey burger
turkey burger we're almost done okay so
I got my Sriracha I got my mayonnaise
you need some help no I'm good I'm good
Gordon I'm just I mean I mean oh over
there you're going next level multiple
things here we go we got our slime just
gonna toss this around again red cabbage
uh green cabbage all these fresh flavors
I'm gonna throw in some of these apples
and I'm ready to play Gordon you played
it already oh my gosh you're already
done is the platform coming I am the
platform on the way oh my god listen I'm
not toasting my bun because my meat is
cooked beautifully let's get this going
right here I got some cilantro can I do
anything no we gotta listen I'm good I'm
good just just let me know when that
platform's there here we go a little bed
of the cilantro turkey burgers going
right on top time for that slaw Super
Fresh super healthy there we go we'll go
lots of lots of slaw keep it nice and
messy Lots really delicious serve it
open face because the platform is on the
way Gordon
fell asleep you better get your Burgers
okay okay finally serious right next to
yours look at that I don't know I don't
know I was late but they both look
delicious
[Music]
to get the ingredients and more details
on the fabulous recipes from tonight's
cook-off please check the description
below and be sure to subscribe for more
episodes of Next Level kitchen with this
genius great job let's eat
[Music]